why do you think it is that people are
so comfortable constantly being
comfortable and they can't put
themselves in a position of voluntary
suffering because you don't need to how
do people get fat like one day at a time
where they eat 200 calories or th000
calories more than they expended over
and over and over again over a very very
long period of time there's no reason to
put yourself through suffering we can go
from an air conditioned house to a
heated seat car we can Uber eat
ourselves a well-cooked meal while we
watch Netflix on the TV that we Amazon
primed to ourselves so many of the rough
edges of Life have been ER people have
built buildings inside of which there
are heavy things that you pay to have
access to so that you can go in and lift
these heavy things up and then put them
down in the same place and it's called a
gym we've had to artificially create
discomfort in our own lives because it's
been completely eroded from our normal
existence there's a difference between
what you want and what is good for you
and what people want is often immediate
comfort and what is good for you is some
degree of resilience training things
that are good for you typically have
pain immediately and pleasure in the
long run